♫ Ring, ring the banjo
♫ Take it long chimmel and chucker
♫ Camp town ladies sing this song
♫ Say
♫ With my banjo do dah day
♫ Oh ♫
(Bouncy acapella music)
(laughter)
(lively, jazzy music)
(bass rock music)
(whistle)
(heroic music)
(school bell rings)
(children's laughter)
(marching music)
♫ Try to trust in your friends
♫ One at a time
♫ It's the best thing to do
♫ If you lean on a buddy
♫ Who's twice as good for you
♫ For you ♫
- This whomps.
Run. Run run run run run!
(hockey stick hits ground)
(fast paced rock music)
- Hey Daria.
- [Quinn] But moooommm...
Daria's walking into my shot and
I don't want to be seen with her.
(slow paced rock music)
- Hey babe!
(fast techno music)
(all three yell)
- Oh no, it's raining!
(Misty cries)
- Hey I know, I'll use
my trusty frying pan
as a drying pan!
(groans)
Oh hey Nurse Joy, let's get married!
Please, give me a Chansey!
- [Helga] Arnold...
(fast jazz music)
Arnold... Arnold...
Hey Arnold!
Move it Football Head!
Oh, my sweet, sweet love.
(bicycle bell)
(Eugene moans)
(crashing noise)
- [Eugene] I'm okay.
- Daria, smile!
- I don't like to smile
unless I have a reason.
- [Quinn] It's too bad
Sandy couldn't make it.
Say cheese!
- [Group] Cheese.
(Acapella music)